[Music]
tattling was the first town in Suffolk
to be recognized formally as working
from a dementia of dementia friendly
community and the dementia Action
Alliance were formed back in February
2015
initially sue Carver community health
and well-being officer was involved in
the primary meeting and was really
integral in getting the stakeholders
together the Alliance is made up of
volunteers stakeholders and initially
having Weber and mid Suffolk support
made us a safe place to talk to in terms
of stakeholder engagement so that was
really important for me as chair of the
Alliance when we set up the Alliance is
based in Stowe Market and surrounding
villages and we're very keen to work
with all organizations all businesses
but very much more with people living
with dementia their families and carers
the council has been brilliant with
regard to support to the Alliance we are
very fortunate to have a member of the
council sitting on the steering group
and they've also been helpful supporting
events it was really important to have
the support of favour of mid Suffolk
District Council because it provides the
support that we need it also heightens
the awareness of the Alliance and how
important it is to all members of the
Stowe market community the relationship
I'd like to say that I have with favor
amid Suffolk is a very close one
they have also worked with us to create
advance smooth event and in May this
year they are going to be supporting us
to deliver a memory walk using the
facilities of the Abbott tool and the
museum I'd like to thank sook Alva paper
and mid Suffolk District Council for her
support and commitment to our work with
the snow market dementia alliance it's
been really appreciative without her we
most probably wouldn't have achieved as
much as we have thank you
you